this is what it looked like as storms
were pounding the valley especially the
central part of the valley rolling right
through las vegas you can see the just
cluster of rain just falling right from
the roof wow love having all of our
shutter bugs like david woods sending us
video and photos of the storm all night
that water gushing there onto the poker
table just crazy downtown las vegas same
kind of deal this is inside circa the
newest resort in downtown las vegas well
it has the same old problems flooding
look at the bottom of your screen the
all that water on the floor of the
sports book there quite a mess to clean
up and another familiar sight during a
storm this one happening at the link
parking garage looking like a river here
ken camp sharing video the flood water
running right through it now the parking
garage was designed as a flood basin to
kind of help control the water flow but
you know that area and you know when to
stay away from it here's what it looked
like for folks trying to get to reed
international last night looks like a
river they're driving through not
supposed to drive in that kind of stuff
if you don't have to and even if you
have to you really shouldn't anyway